yankspeaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business protect it at
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
you have at this point de-radicalized
how many people would you say
anywhere over 600 people i think now if
i
am someone who's struggling uh with
trying to disengage from one of these
uh movements or organizations uh like
what is your
approach to that person it's typically
never the ideology that they're after
right the ideology is not
attractive it's illogical it's
irrational
uh to hate somebody based on the color
of their skin i mean it's based on
conspiracy theories
and garbage so it's not the ideology
so we have to understand um as people
are on the search for identity
community and purpose which we all are
at some point in our lives sometimes
multiple times in our lives
we hit what i call potholes in our
life's journey and potholes are things
like
physical trauma and abuse could be
mental illness it could be job loss it
could be grief it could be poverty can
also be privileged
if privilege keeps us too separate from
humanity it could be millions of
different things and those potholes lead
us to the fringes they detour us
and on the fringes they're all sorts of
narratives to try and comfort us to try
and
uh kind of take advantage of our
vulnerability white supremacists are
waiting there too to try and attract
people with a narrative that takes their
pain
and projects it on to somebody else so
my goal when i work with people is
really to
listen very closely to those potholes
and then try and repair them as best as
i can because once the potholes are
repaired we can work on replacing
the toxic identity community and purpose
that they've found
that they're getting a reward from with
something that's more
positive
[Music]
and we're back andrew did you watch the
debate i know you watched it babe
what do you think man did i watch the
debate
i lived it and no i didn't quite like it
but uh
i was uh he lived in the studio i guess
right yeah i lived in the studio that's
true
um and so uh watched it
commentated on it and came away thinking
that uh trump did a whole lot better
than he did the first time it really
made you reflect on if he had delivered
this performance the first time
i think the dynamics of this race would
be very different but i think
that um by any standard the first debate
was the most important one so
if there was one that you did not want
to tank it was that one
uh and he he did and so his better
performance this time i don't think
will change the dynamics of those but i
think it will stop the bleeding somewhat
where i think his support was uh
shrinking
um and it has been shrinking since the
first debate
and then him getting kovid and then this
general sense that his campaign's a mess
and then him running around rallying in
various
uh states i i don't know if that has
moved the needle
uh it seems like uh
frankly a kind of desperate uh game plan
like in in the final days particularly
because some other rallies have been in
places that
uh are generally safely red and um
so they're they're trying anything at
this point
um but i do think it was a better
performance for him
uh and think that uh i found myself kind
of
like grateful that he hadn't didn't do
this performance in the first debate
he was good like trump was for him he
was he was good he was
clearly i think you tweeted he'd been
he'd been he'd been coached in practice
yeah you tweeted like trump looks like
he prepared which is a statement because
i think
i mean he like i think they they really
press on
this in 2016 that he prepared for
hillary in various ways i think chris
christie was involved with the stories i
remember reading
um but he looked more calm i think the
nature of it where they were muting um
um you could see like his like tendency
to like kind of start interrupting and
then kind of
dial it back at times um he was strong
um
that said i thought um this was one of
joe's better performances
um from like a he was articulate
he was strong he punched back pretty
hard um
i thought way better great moments great
points he was flexible
um he he he both stayed on message and
also
seemed like he was very present like it
you never got a vibe
where he was just um going towards
prepared talking points he was
responding to trump
in the moment uh i agree with you i
thought i thought joe was very strong at
uh
various points so here's my question for
you
when we were running for president um
the big thing was
not just to do well in the moment um and
actually like by the numbers like a lot
of people tune out after the first
30 minutes or so particularly in the
primaries i'm not sure about the
presidentials but it's probably
something similar
um the big thing was yeah ideally you
get a hit in or two in the early
moments um but then you wanted the sound
bite
you know which we hated trying to fight
for and you particularly hated it i
did too um where you want that like
little gotcha moment where the press can
clip it and then it's like did you see
that last night like cory booker said
joe you're
drinking the wrong kool-aid whoever the
hell they're selling i mean you remember
this [ __ ]
um and then what happened in the primary
a lot was there other there was other
news cycles going on there was an
impeachment going on
there was uh eventually coronavirus but
like the press there used to be weeks
almost of like earned media after debate
and then it kept get shrinking and
shrinking and there was one debate we
had where there was literally no earned
it was like you got that night coverage
and maybe a little bit more and that's
it
so you don't get the bump my question is
like
what what has has anything i haven't
seen that much come
out of this debate from a like press
angle
story there's a good amount about biden
i think misspoke about how he wanted to
get rid of oil
which it's probably not going to pull
well pennsylvania and probably will hurt
him
particularly from attack ads from the
trump ad administration uh thoughts on
what the media is spinning after this
and what's happening um in the sound
bite world
i think uh i think they're kind of
over it already honestly like i i don't
think that they're gonna be really
clipping from this debate
uh and um trump
is an endless fountain of new content so
reporters can simply just go to his
rallies and see what
anytime he's going to provide you get
your clicks
i've been looking into what election
night looks like and we can talk some
more about this
um but there are a lot of variables
uh and the the main variable is around
um states i can report that night and
then states that probably will not be
able to
um so i think that's where the press is
going to head honestly i think the press
is going to start trying to prepare the
public for
election night because it's not going to
be
the usual okay we're there we watch it
you announce the winner
someone concedes and then we know who
the president is at
let's call it uh 11 30 eastern time um
like
it seems like that probably does not
play out this time so i think
that's where the press is heading so i'm
uh
you know you and i now like are are part
of our careers tied to politics right so
i have um
and now that i'm off the race my friends
feel a little better about texting me
because i'm i'm a little
definitely better about responding um so
i'm i'm getting
my republican friends and my um except
my family in florida i grew up outside
of hartford and um
right and so i have people friends all
over the spectrum and
to me it feels like
republicans and democrats are in
completely different worlds right now
like they like what on one hand there's
a fandom aspect like you're rooting for
your guy
and you know you hear what you want to
hear and you know you're rooting for you
know the republicans thought
trump did well and the democrats thought
biting you pretty well too like that you
know that standard most of time
but i think we're like the problem
right in the left and some of the social
media stuff we talked about like they're
just feeding us different
[ __ ] all the time and so i want your
thoughts on this like to me the worst
case scenario is actually not
trump winning if you if you don't like
trump right it's actually
to me where no one knows the source of
truth and who [ __ ] won
you know what i'm saying where um if
trump's like
it's not over you know it's the
prolonged
process where it drags on for
days and weeks uh and the and
people don't just stand idly by during
those days and weeks so people protest
people uh in some cases potentially
uh are violent or destroyed property or
um you know something that's
truly destructive that's a real danger
i mean that that's i think again why the
press is going to be turning towards
what the
mechanics will look like on election
night and thereafter
because many people in the press are
going to be trying to dampen
any unrest um but there is going to be
some i'm sure uh media figures at the
margins
like the [ __ ] the folks who are
um better served by something
nasty and dramatic happening who might
be fanning the flames
so uh you know and the fact is
we're days away from voting and at this
point almost 50 million americans have
already voted including me yeah
same here we did it yeah we did it so if
you haven't voted
join you're hearing zach join the club
we did it 40
some odd millions we can do it you
definitely can do it because we yeah
we're not great
my voting record is not sterling it's
put it that way so that the mechanics
are hugely important and the
if you're with joe and kamala
uh the states to keep an eye on in terms
of an early result would be florida and
north carolina
um yeah if they report and they go to
joe then this could be a wrap election
night and they
they can count theirs before election
night so they should be able to report
relatively on time compared to other
states
like i believe i think it's ohio i can't
remember they can't start counting until
election day right
the the three late counting states uh
bully for them
is uh um the the three to keep an eye on
that are slow
are michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania
okay
as you can tell those are key
battleground states
so if you want to avoid a long process
you need to get a pretty good-looking
sweep
of some big electoral prizes like
florida north carolina if you're joe
the upside is that trump can win florida
north carolina and he frankly should be
favored to win both those places they're
both like a little bit right leaning
um so he can win those and joe can still
win ultimately win
um so it's it's funny it's one-way
traffic where
if florida and north carolina go for joe
it's probably a wrap um if florida
and carolina go for trump it is not a
wrap um
it just means that the process is gonna
drag on
and trump may call it a rap if that's
you know he's gonna call it a rap at
some point
um theoretically that's a little
terrible all he does
tweet i won concede joe whatever it is
and we have a
civil war i don't know what do we do
then i don't know
we have a we have a press and media
narrative war and probably a series of
protests of some kind
um yeah we'll see i mean the social
media companies have said they're going
to clamp down on any
uh un verified or un
um independently stated victory
proclamation
so our buddy jack our buddy alexis
from reddit uh jack dorsey twitter
mark zuckerberg is on our buddy but uh
like hopefully
they do they do democracy a favor if you
will and this does put pressure on the
media organizations who will be the
independent verifiers
[Music]
if you're listening to this show you
probably love podcasts i want to
recommend one that
we've been listening to and dabbling
into and um
that has some fascinating stuff that's
made for the yang gang in many ways
remain for our listeners in many ways so
the jordan harbinger show is what we're
talking about and i just listened to one
with a guy named david shimmer who comes
and talks about
how our elections have been kind of
covertly interfered with
for the past 100 years so like election
interference is not new
it is something that's been happening
for a while sometimes it's foreign
sometimes it's harmless
sometimes it doesn't affect the election
at all sometimes it's massive it was
really fascinating to listen to this guy
uh just jordan just has his ability to
talk to some of those brilliant minds
out there and make it simple for us to
simple and actionable for us to take
things away so
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h a r b
as in boy i n as in nancy g e r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcast
so that's jordan harbinger's show you
can google it you can find it on
podcasts and it's
um it's worth your time it's worth your
energy it's worth your intellectual
curiosity frankly so a ton interesting
people check it out jordan harbin new
show
he's the harbinger of knowledge
we're in touch with the biden team and
in in their uh relative inner circles um
you know not entering but you know we're
in the loop on some stuff and
there's so much there's so many
logistics around mail-in voting and
remote voting and
like the way that's happening this year
and to me what i'm scared of and i love
your thoughts on this
what what scares me is that
if you're trump you have
the white house um an entire
administration
and staff and infrastructure to navigate
this
across the country and if you're joe
you've had to build that from scratch
right like if you need people on the
ground dealing with the secretary of
state
in ohio or florida or dealing with the
frankly the post offices
in various counties and states all over
the country
joe's had to build that from scratch you
know literally hiring people on the fly
as you go
does that freak you out like that's
what's scary to me where it's like
i think the dems could pull this off but
it's going to be tight
and the margin of error is going to lean
towards
republicans or the incumbent if you will
you know i from what i've heard it seems
like they've mobilized a lot of
resources in those directions
like around uh yeah they have a lot of
money and lawyers and the rest of it
yeah
so uh and they're they're competent
um where i don't think they're just
going to
not see that particular quote-unquote
battleground coming
um i mean they do see it coming and i
know they're staffing up for it yeah
yeah they're smart and jen i mean jen
their campaign manager is
is really sharp um so
this is to kind of close the loop on
this this was a debate recap if you will
i don't think anything
true super fundamental except um if
they're people that were like leaving
the trump train
because they thought he was off the
rails in the last debate they may have
jumped back on
given his pretty good performance um
i hate these debates i think they're
actually a waste of time
generally speaking i would love to ask
you this and i kind of talked about it
last time we did a debate recap
if you had to fix the debates because
you're great at these ideas how would
you fix them like if you were like blank
slate
andrew yang creates the debate you're
not in it uh let's say in this in this
made-up fantasy i'm having how would you
how would you structure them to you
i would try and build something that
actually
takes advantage of modern technology so
something asynchronous where
for example you could ask both
candidates 10 questions they have
x let's call it a minute to answer or
two minutes to answer each question
and just play the recordings and then
you can watch it uh ahead of time
um and then when you show up for the
debate you can have follow-ups instead
of
you sort of dig beneath like the first
two minutes of content
interesting yeah the problem in these
dates is that
they revolve around certain subject
areas that you you can prepare for you
know
you can go to like a couple of um uh
of canned answers uh
and so um instead of frankly like being
like hey what do you think about this
uh like policy on the superficial level
you could just do that ahead of time
um and then you could spend the debate
doing something uh deeper
and try and elicit more real info for
voters
so that that's my idea um you'd have a
little bit of pre-work i think it'd be a
bonanza for
a lot of these networks too personally
because it still makes the live thing
super important
you know but but then you you could have
like a touch point ahead of time there'd
be more genuine information
um yeah getting transferred to the
public too
that is i've never thought that andrew
and i think so one of the things you
watch this debate it's like
they're both arguing their own set of
facts you know where they cite their own
studies and look for every one study
that says climate change is real there's
another
fewer and fewer frankly but there's
there's another it says it's you know
it's
not man-made or happening without us or
it's a hoax or whatever the hell you
want you know what i really dislike zac
is the spin afterwards
where it's like talk about all the
realities you go to the teams
and it does not matter what happens like
my candidate was incredible
we need to do our listeners a favor and
just kind of walk them through what the
[ __ ] spin room's like because the
average american has no idea what this
is
it's i'll start just so you walk after
the debate they funnel you they heard
you like cats through these like little
winding areas and then they dump you in
a big room
which is usually freezing cold um and
it's
basically like an l where all the
networks have their little boots around
it where they're live on like the cnn
panel
all the stuff you see and then in the
middle is what i
no other way to describe it but a [ __ ]
show of reporters like just a
[ __ ] swarm paparazzi style
of just mics in your face and then the
candidates come in
so if you're not that if you're not the
front runner right if you're like let's
call it michael bennett
and you've got a bunch of reporters on
it's the only candidate there but then
joe biden walks in
all the reporters just literally run
away from you they just [ __ ] say
peace out
oh man there's joe biden they just leave
you mid interview i'm like
like talk to me more about like your
experience here because it wasn't me i
was the one like hurting you around but
you were the one with the mics in your
face
and then having them ripped out of your
face you know
yeah it was always bizarre uh and
there was like a hierarchy in the media
around like candidates where
for us depending how hot we were at a
particular moment in time it would be
like uh you know you can like queue up
and like wait your turn
or you could not and uh
um you know and then they're always like
trying i mean they called it the spin
room you know i was like pushing these
narratives
um i think some of like the top tier
candidates just skipped it
um you know yeah joe like almost never
did it
um warren barely did it but they would
get like physically assaulted like i
remember catching elizabeth
warren and her staffer because reporters
were tripping over themselves and
they're like falling like oh
yeah because there are some people from
like marginal press outlets that are
just trying to get a juicy quote oh yeah
the new like the norwegian outlet's
always there like in your face like
whatever the hell it is right
the european ones are the worst and i
was always trying to be congenial and
like
responsible because you know any any
journalist trying to get
info out of me i'm like well you're
doing me a favor so let me try and help
you but then
that doesn't serve you well in that
environment because if you're nice to
one then all of a sudden like 10 mics
will
like get jammed in your face and like
each one will throw a different question
at you to try and get
like a 30 second response that's
exclusive to them yeah uh yeah
good good times it was it was like a
feeding frenzy
yeah and the hardest part was always the
timing to me because like
basically if you're fox you've got your
panel going on you're like all right and
you're talking so i'm like oh we're
gonna go live with
amy klobuchar right now and they got amy
right and so that's like a timing and a
cadence
in order to get in on that timing and
cadence you have to have good
relationships with all the bookers
and show producers and reporters within
there so when we were first starting we
didn't know anybody
um we had people we hired who kind of
knew people um so we're like hey do you
want andrew yang you're like yeah but
after kamala or like whatever the hell
and we're just like sometimes standing
there awkwardly it's like so
oh i hated it i hated it
i hated it you know what what one debate
evelyn came with me
that was fun and evelyn's like this i
mean yeah she was like this is a
disaster like
what is happening like i don't know the
real human
reaction to that shark pit is pretty
crazy
uh that's enough debate stuff let's move
on we've got christian peak
peachelini i do that right christian
peachelini
yeah who's really fascinating guy and
andrew you knew him i think before you
ever ran
right i connected with him very early
in my run because okay of my
uh my book the war on normal people i've
been deeply concerned about
the marginalization of many uh people
from our economy but also from american
life
and in some cases that leads to
radicalization
and that radicalization has been
facilitated greatly by the internet
where
today if you have any set of ideas
you might be able to develop a following
from those ideas
on some forum somewhere read it for
channie chan
uh you know wherever and a lot of those
forms are perfectly benign but then some
of them are
the opposite of benign um and so i've
been
fixated on what we can do about these
radicalized individuals and communities
many of which
adhere to very hateful racist theologies
and christian peacholini to me is a
singular
figure and that he lived it he led a
white supremacist gang for the better
part of a decade
then he came out and now he relates his
own experience
both in the movement as he calls it but
then afterwards trying to help
dozens even hundreds of people
de-radicalize and re-enter american life
and if you see what's going on right now
in america this is going to become
more and more important and
i learned from christian i quoted him on
the debate stage once i don't know if
you remember the zack where they
asked me about this issue um and
uh he's written two incredible books
that i know of
uh uh and i thought talking to him was
very important in this moment because a
lot of what we're talking about with the
potential rancor and unrest around this
election
is tied into these communities
these ideologies and the temptation for
a lot of people
is just to um say well
you know these people are uh deeply
wrong immoral damaged and have to be
condemned and cast away yeah
cast away and uh expunged
um to the fullest extent possible
uh by any of our media platforms social
media platforms
and i understand why people feel that
way i do think that we need to do
more certainly on the social media front
to make it difficult
for people to spread hateful ideas and
ideologies
but i think christian's approach is much
more
human experience driven
nuanced and we should be
putting massive levels of resources
towards it
because the way of a problem is not uh
to deny its existence
or to um or or to
just say to everyone like let's condemn
it um i mean sometimes condemnation is
called foreign it's good
uh you know particularly from people in
positions of prominence
uh but that that will not solve most
problems really
especially when you're looking at a
problem that has been festering because
of
frayed social connections uh and frayed
and disintegrating past forward in many
many communities among
um young men who
tend to be more prone to some of these
um
these ideologies so learn a lot from
christian i hope
people enjoy uh learning from him as
well i think he's a very very important
leader
uh and most importantly like uh human
who's been through some things that
really lead us
in a better direction it's one of the
things i really love about you andrew
and i always love working with you
you're a lot better at this than i am
where i think
that you just said this like the
tendency when you hear these racial
racist thoughts or these these nazi
groups are these really really dark
places
a lot of people are like get rid of them
screw you go away throw on the rug
and you say that but then you're like
that's also not helpful
right where there's especially when
these thoughts are growing that
christian talks about these groups are
growing in numbers or popularity in some
some
areas of the country right now there's a
reason
for that and there's a human element to
figuring out why and how you can help
people from joining and that's where
your head goes really naturally
and not a lot of people do you know you
know what i'm saying and you've kind of
always done that
i'm like an and person it's like yes say
that it's wrong
and like what are the other facets of
this problem that we can do something
about
yeah that's a good improv for you man
yes and but
um look this is a fascinating episode
it's like
in the weeds on a world that no one
really gets to see
um in a good way in a helpful human
positive um
beneficial way so christian picciolini
joining yang speaks
tune in guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what yang speaks we're serious
about our data
is our property we should have control
over it we should know what happens to
it
now while we're waiting for congress to
get its act together what can we do to
actually protect our data
expressvpn is the software that i and
thousands
of listeners use every day to protect
our data online
i've been talking about expressvpn on my
show for so long now that
most of you already signed up i'm
kidding
if you have it why should you uh
it's like a button where it'll beam you
to another
part of the internet and then whatever
you do no one knows what you did
you know what i mean it's like uh and
that's why
corporations use it so they can have
their employees do things and not have
it be monitored by the
internet service provider or anyone else
or the big tech companies
or the data brokers so if that sounds
appealing to you
you should definitely check out
expressvpn because they are
top rated by cnet wired and a lot of
other folks who just
look at virtual private networks all day
and say which one of you
should i recommend and they settled on
expressvpn
so my question is why haven't you gotten
expressvpn yet
our link expressvpn.com
will give you an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
protect your data today with a vpn i
trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn.com to get started
one of the things about these vpns out
there that is not expressvpn like some
of the cheap knockoffs is that they
actually
sell your data so that's how they make
their money and
one of the reasons we actually looked
into the vpn options why we love
expressvpn they they don't
do that so they're actually aligned with
what we stand for at humanity forward
and
and ng's presidential run so check this
out guys protect yourself
vpn that we use and trust so use our
link
expressvpn expressvpn.com today
get an extra three months free on a one
year package
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks uh
the founder of free radicals the author
of several great books uh on
confronting extremism particularly white
supremacy his latest book breaking hate
is a book i'm a huge fan of christian
picholini hey andrew how are you
it's good to talk to you again it's good
to talk to you again too uh
you're someone that i cited on the
campaign trail
including during one of the debates
because of your incredible background
um where you spent almost 10 years
deep in the white nationalist movement
you were the head of a
like a gang uh you fronted one of the
early well maybe not early but like one
of the most significant
uh white supremacist rock bands
um where you performed internationally
even in europe at like a show for
thousands
um and you and i connected on the
campaign trail because
you have taken your experiences
and used them to try and get people out
of those movements today
yeah thank you very much and i have to
tell you i would think i was sitting in
like a hotel room in minneapolis when i
was watching the debate and then
when you mentioned my name it took a
second or two for it to register and
then i jumped up screaming because you
pronounced my name correctly so thank
you for that that was that was a really
awesome moment i appreciate that
after i said your name on the debate
stage uh
did you get a bunch of text messages
like yo i think this dude just said your
name
i i did i did i think my wife was that
was the first one she was back home in
chicago
and and then just kind of the phone lit
up after that but yeah no it's been a
while
and i really appreciate that you know
and and i appreciate it too because it
really has brought
a lot of exposure to the work that i do
with free radicals project and a lot of
people have reached out to me
to try and get help disengaging from
extremism because of that mention
so thank you for that you really kind of
brought some exposure to
you know for help that people didn't
know existed well thank you
for actually providing the help and
using your
experience to help shed some light on a
problem that many many americans
care deeply about but are casting about
for real solutions
yeah you're one of the very very few
people
on earth in my opinion that has been
doing this work and can offer
real solutions uh to help people
combat hatred and extremism so we'd love
to talk
about and you know i talked about this
even on the debate stage where
you were radicalized when you were very
young uh
and i think your story is indicative but
let's assume that the folks listening to
this
uh this is their first time ever hearing
about christian and your story
so can you walk us through how you wound
up
leading a white nationalist group yeah
absolutely
um you know i uh i was
14 years old in 1987 when i was
recruited into america's first neo-nazi
skinhead gang
on the south side of chicago and i spent
eight years of my life until i was
almost 23 years old
as a member of that gang but also
eventually
a leader within that gang and then
somebody who did travel overseas and was
you know kind of very early in the youth
part of the white supremacist movement
in america
kind of the 1.0 version of what we're
seeing today or what we saw
in charlottesville uh frankly but you
know it's really important to mention
before that andrew i you know before i
was 14 and was standing in an alley
smoking a joint and this guy came up to
me
you know pulled the joint out of my
mouth looked me in the eyes and said
that's what the communists and the jews
want you to do
to keep you docile because that's how i
was recruited literally standing in an
alley
and you know i didn't know what the hell
a communist was i didn't know what a jew
was i didn't know what the word docile
meant at 14 years old
but it was the first time in my life
that i felt as though somebody had paid
attention to me because before i was
you know recruited that day i came from
kind of a normal family
my parents are italian immigrants who
came to the us in the mid 60s
and they were really working almost you
know
18 hours a day seven days a week to
survive so
you know not only was i not raised
around hate and i was raised by an
immigrant family
but i was also surrounded by a lot of
love because i had grandparents and
aunts and uncles who took care of me
when my parents weren't there
i had a brother who was 10 years younger
than me
but um on july 3rd when he was 20 years
old he was murdered
in a gang shooting unfortunately
so i went most of my life kind of as an
only child but before that like i was
surrounded by a lot of love like it
wasn't i wasn't raised in a hateful
environment my parents weren't racist
they had friends from all over the world
but what i was looking for
really was a family like i felt
abandoned by my parents
even though i knew they loved me they
just weren't around and i wasn't mature
enough to ask so i went looking
for a family and that guy in that alley
when i was 14 years old
offered that to me offered me a sense of
identity he offered me a community and
he offered
me a purpose all three of which i was
searching desperately for and couldn't
find
anywhere um you and i are now like you
know grown men
and and whatnot um i'm trying to imagine
14 year old you
like i i i can see in you that you know
eventually you became
uh literally like a hate rock singer so
like you know
you probably cast a particular profile
um when i was 14
as an example you know like i was skinny
and awkward and like you know
no one's i'm just wondering like whether
um there was anything about you at that
time that screamed like hey come
radicalize me like you know i i'd
imagine
not i'd imagine you were you know
fairly nondescript no i was pretty
invisible at 14 years old i was
uh you know kind of so i mean my dilemma
was i was raised on the southwest side
of chicago
um in an italian neighborhood
but my parents had moved me when i was
born to
you know kind of an affluent white
neighborhood to go to school there but i
never spent any time
you know after school so i never made
any friends there and i never made any
friends in the italian neighborhood
because they saw me as an outsider too
so i just didn't
i was invisible um and uh but i was also
ambitious my parents were entrepreneurs
they had started a small business and my
grandparents had us i mean it's like
that's all i knew so i almost saw this
as an opportunity for entrepreneurship
at 14 years old i went
out on my own to try and make it on my
own
and took you know was led down the wrong
path for sure
so your parents must have been shocked
when at some point you come back and
you're like hey you shave your head you
you're like hey i'm a skinhead now and
like i'm living with these people and
working with these people and you know
like you you for went uh college for
like quite some time obviously to be
doing the work you were doing they were
horrified
uh the minute they figured out what i
was involved in they were
you know horrified and they tried
everything that they could to to get me
out but
at that point i was already using it as
a weapon against them
you know i started to you know denigrate
immigrants because they were
immigrants i started to really kind of
amplify everything that i knew
was getting at them because i was pissed
off that they you know had abandoned me
or at least that's what i thought back
then i don't think that now
but that's what i thought at 14 and at
15 and at 18 i felt like i needed to
punish them
for leaving me so i amplified everything
that they hated
because you know what teenager rebels
against their parents by you know
upholding their values they did
everything that they hated
and it pulled me deeper into the
movement because of that but i also
definitely started to believe what i was
getting into and
and then used it as a weapon against
them it was awful and i feel
ashamed for that and i've you know i
should say i've connected with my
parents that we have a great
relationship
um but it was a really rough you know
eight years that i was involved
i i think this is a really important
idea
or phenomenon because
you weren't i'm sure the only 14 year
old kid who feels
angry i mean i was very angry at 14.
uh and that anger plays out in different
ways
you know like for different people and
the fact that you might embrace
something simply because it's kind of a
reaction
um to something else i think it is
a dynamic that's really powerful it's
like playing out in various like how do
you rebel like you said it's like well
i'm immigrant parents
and i'm pissed off at them then like you
know maybe this ideology is something
that uh can be used to hurt them yeah
i'm thinking about what i was angry
about
when i was 14 and i was quite angry um
you know i think that
uh that there are
i think that there are certain periods
in our lives where it's almost
uh unavoidable to be trying to find some
sense of belonging
um and for me i'll speak for myself i
was one of the only
non-white kids in my town um and so
there was like a sense of
me like alienation that that came with
that
um in my case like my anger manifested
self and me
eventually uh taking out martial arts
and working out a little bit too much
and like
uh you know dressing like a skater and
pretty harmless [ __ ]
like you know like relatively speaking
um but there are
different versions of it different forms
of rebellion
certainly i think uh often
experimenting with drugs can be part of
it like there are different behaviors
you can take on
yeah i mean i think part of me was also
looking screaming for attention
you know from my parents and then when i
got it and i i recognized what kind of
power that
wielded i used it against them um you
know kind of you know as punishment
almost for what for what they had done
to me i wasn't you know i didn't know
how to deal with it maturely and
and i got involved in some stuff that i
ended up believing and then i
not only used it against them but i used
it against a lot of people um you know i
made music that that still
despite my attempts to try and have it
removed lives on in the internet you
know
i put ideas out into the world that you
know i take full accountability for and
i still 20 years after
you know 20 plus years after i've left
um
have held myself accountable for um i
planted a lot of
seeds it's one reason why you're such an
important and compelling figure to me
christian because you have folks who
look at
these ideas uh and in your case it's
like look i
i held some very noxious terrible uh
hateful ideas at a certain point but
then eventually i realized that they
were wrong and now i'm trying to help
others in the same direction so i feel
like you are
in many ways like a living
um like map as to
how these transformations can take place
and be reversed
which is to me so important because
again so many americans are casting
about for
real solutions so tell us more about
your
uh eight or nine years uh as part of the
movement um you literally ended up a
leader of one of like the biggest
um gangs in illinois it sounded like
uh after the leader that preceded you
was jailed i believe
yeah so yeah and i mean to be clear it
was
there was nothing that anybody who i
thought i hated ever did
there was nothing that they ever did to
me to make me hate them uh it was me
hating myself and really projecting that
self-hatred onto other people and i
think that's the case
for anybody involved in these movements
because certainly you know nobody else
is to blame for their hatred um you know
during those eight years
um it was it started out with just kind
of a fascination with the camaraderie
you know the music and the fashion of it
kind of brought us together it developed
a really clear sense
of identity so at first it was pretty
benign it you know i just felt like
it was a group of guys i was 14 i didn't
you know i wasn't very politically
minded or anything like that it took me
a while to learn that stuff
but very quickly by the time i was 16
the guy who had recruited me in that
alley clark martell
and i should say too this was the
chicago area skinners was the very first
neo-nazi skinhead gang in america
so it was already kind of this infamous
group and the guy who had recruited me
was this really infamous skinhead leader
he was the first
kind of white power skinhead leader and
he had gone to jail at 16 when i was 16
years old and he was
he was several years older than me like
10 years older than me
and several other people had gone to
jail for a really brutal
hate crime um involving another young
girl who was a skinhead but had
been seen with a black man and they had
gone her apartment and pistol-whipped
her and it was a really awful
situation but he had gone to prison and
so had everybody else that was part of
this small group or they were running
away from the law
and here i was like this barely 16 year
old kid who wasn't involved in that
because i was too young to have been
brought out to something like that
and i was essentially the last man
standing so everybody else was gone and
here i was this you know 16 year old kid
who
now was the only one left in this very
famous infamous gang
and i took it over and i started to
recruit people that were younger than me
i started to recruit you know my peers
some people kind of came back over time
and suddenly i you know had gone from
this invisible 14 year old
to this you know 16 and 17 year old who
had
this tremendous amount of and i'm
putting up air quotes for those who are
just listening
respect i didn't have respect but that's
what it felt like
and that really intoxicated me and i
started to get more involved in
kind of paving the way for new things
within that movement like making music i
was in
the first american band of that genre to
leave and
travel overseas and perform um so i
spread it around
unfortunately now the name of the band
was
way white american youth i believe
yeah i had two bands unfortunately in
the name of the other one was
actually worse it was final solution
that's the ban i performed in germany
illegally i should say
so you are uh the last man
standing at the age of 16 17. uh
was there like a physical clubhouse or
environment like
like where did convenings take place how
are you living at this point were you
still living with your family
yeah um no i mean there was really no
formal structure it was
you know kind of a gang we convened in
people's basements and backyards and
parking lots
um i had moved out kind of at 15 and a
half
or so uh and commandeered my you know
the basement
of of my parents uh you know multi-unit
flat
and uh kind of turned it into an
apartment with a separate entrance and
everything
so i was living on my own at a fairly
early age against my parents wishes even
though it was still under
technically under their roof so we did a
lot of things there we had a held a lot
of meetings there
um it was it operated a lot like a gang
might we intimidated people
um you know we got in fights it was
physical
we spread propaganda um you know this
was all pre-internet so we didn't
have you know that kind of platform so
it was very face to face we would stand
outside of you know
arcades and punk rock shows with flyers
and try to recruit you know
other vulnerable looking kids
well we'll certainly talk about the
internet um a little bit later on
because
you know that has been such an
accelerant to a lot of
these ideologies and problems
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the toughest things during this
pandemic
is feeling good about yourself
physically a lot of it has to do with
what you're putting in your body
we're all about trying to promote
people's healthy diets
here at yang speaks and one thing that's
done the trick
for me and a lot of other people is
athletic greens
i love it because you can just do it
every day it's super easy it's super
convenient just mix it together
add water you drink it and you feel like
you've just had
a whole lot of nutrients and minerals
that your body
has been missing because they're not in
cheetos or whatever the heck you're
eating
so if that sounds like something that
would benefit you definitely check it
out
they've invested a ton of
energy and resources into figuring out
how to support your immune system
keep you healthy give you nutrients in a
way that your body really likes it
in covid right now i'm doing everything
i can just to stay positive and happy
and one of the ways i do that is through
food
yet if i eat like cheese or grease or
stuff like that i
it never it's not necessarily a good
thing now that i'm 32 my body's falling
apart so
i love athletic greens because it
actually helps my gut it actually helps
me digest so i just re-upped my stash of
this stuff i love
it you put it's like a quick packet or a
scoop you throw it in some water mix it
up
tastes fine or really good depending if
you like this stuff which i do
um and you can i feel better when i eat
frankly like crap because i got my
nutrition
i got my multivitamins and i got my like
immune system balanced
um from athletic greens so i'm a big fan
of this product so if you want to invest
in your health and your gut health today
go to athleticgreens.comyang
you'll receive up to a year's supply of
liquid vitamin d for free that's like
liquid sunshine
with your first purchase again that's
athleticgreens.com
yang to get some green in your life you
know you need some green and you're
looking around your kitchen being like
there's nothing green in here
[Applause]
so you become a musician
you have like an international
trip um you have this arc that spans
years
how did when was the first time you
started realizing wait a minute like i'm
not sure how fully i believe these
things
or that this is wrong or that there is
something
uh very dark and hateful that i may not
want to
continue to lead was there a particular
moment or revelation or relationship
i think i had doubts from the time i was
14 years old and that guy came up to me
in that alley
every day until the day i left eight
years later um but you know there
certainly were some moments that were
kind of like trajectory changers
absolutely
um 19 years old i got married uh to you
know
another girl a girl who was 19 years old
we had a child and then two years later
we had another child
so by the time i was 21 i had two kids
and i was a dad and
a husband that helped change me because
my wife wasn't involved
in the movement and when i was home i
didn't want to introduce my family to
that she knew
and she you know begrudgingly you know
went along with it
but i also was a different person at
home so i had
kind of a replacement identity community
and purpose
and that was a massive help also around
1995
just before i left the movement because
i was trying to compromise with my wife
at the time
she didn't want me on the streets i
decided to open a record shop
so to try and make myself more
legitimate but i was selling
racist music that i was importing music
that i was making
and but i was also selling hip hop and
punk rock and
you know black metal and stuff like that
it was called chaos records
uh so it was it was pretty evident that
we were intent on causing chaos
uh but the people i met there they knew
who who i was they knew what i was
selling and they were you know customers
who were
black or brown or jewish or gay and they
treated me like a human being and
and although it wasn't their
responsibility to do that and and
i'm very grateful that they did though
they you know they they didn't have to
do that
um that helped change me i received
compassion from people i didn't even
deserve it from and that was super
powerful you know it was 75 of my
revenue it was pre-internet so people
were coming in from all over the country
from canada to buy it i was one of the
only stores in america that was selling
that kind of music
so 75 of your record store revenue was
from the
um white power racist music like racist
music
wow because myself that that you had
like a fairly normal record store and
then there were like some some people
who were getting
the the stuff like on the you know the
fly on the side but it sounds like that
was most of the revenue that's insane
well it was probably only 10 of my
inventory i didn't even keep it out in
the you know the shelves i kept all the
regular stuff out of the shelves but
still the the racist music was 75 of my
revenue even though it was only 10
of my inventory uh
yeah so that was the business then i
mean clearly it's not like it's a normal
record store with like a
you know like a sideline i mean that
there's essentially a hate
music store no it was it was a hate
music store but then when i pulled that
because i became embarrassed to sell it
because of these new people i was
becoming friendly with
i pulled that music and of course i had
to close the store because i couldn't
even keep the doors open anymore
yeah so that that might have been the
big decision then when you like if you
make the decision to snuff out your
business i mean you have to know that's
happening
my wife also left me she left me at that
same time
i hit rock bottom is what happened i
closed the store my wife left me took
the kids
and i used that opportunity in a very
sneaky and cowardly way
to walk away from the movement i didn't
denounce it uh i didn't tell you know i
told my buddies i'll be back i just need
to go work on my life
be back in a few months i was never
planning on going back
uh it took me about five years before i
kind of denounced it and
faced my past head on i didn't really
start doing that until you know 1999 or
2000
because i was running from i was really
trying to run from who i was as fast as
i could
um until i realized it was killing me to
do that
so in your case uh you went to college i
want to say
um is that correct yeah um
i left the movement 96 took me a couple
of years to really
figure out who i was i got kind of
depressed and then in 99
a friend of mine one of the few friends
i had at the time uh encouraged me to go
apply for a job at ibm and i thought she
was
crazy you know here i was the sex
skinhead full of tattoos i hadn't
i've been kicked out of like six high
schools one of them twice i didn't go to
college i didn't even own a computer at
the time manager and she's like yeah go
apply at ibm
it's a you know new position that they
offered like okay sure
and i went in and it was an entry-level
position uh it was uh setting up um
and uh kind of reef re-imaging all the
computers that like a corporation would
uh buy at once so be like 400 computers
and we'd spend a month you know setting
that up and my first job
was to install all the hundreds of
computers that my old high school
the one i'd gotten kicked out of twice
and they offered me the job and i took
it it was super entry level
and i was terrified because even though
they had no idea about my past
the first day of my first you know my
job out of the movement
was to go set up the computers at my old
high school and i thought i was going to
get fired and they'd you know destroy my
life
um and i went i was terrified
and uh you know moral of the story ibm
eventually sent
me to to go to college but moral of the
story was
i met the man there that day on my first
day of work
who was the old security guard at my old
high school black man
who i whose life i had made hell and he
was the one who changed
my trajectory he's the one who you know
i didn't know what to say to him when i
came across him in the hallway i said
i'm sorry
his name's john holmes i said i'm sorry
mr holmes and he looked at me
kind of scared because i had made his
life hell when i had gone to that school
and he said
you know sorry makes you feel good it
doesn't do a whole lot for me
so i think you know you need to repair
the damage you've done and he embraced
me
this was a man i'd hurt a black guy who
you know in my heyday was
i made his life hell and he embraced me
and he said i
you know i believe in you and and i
think you need to tell your story and
that was in 1999
uh and i started uh telling my story in
roughly
january of 2000 20 years ago changed my
life you saved my life i don't know that
i would have made it without him
well i'd say extraordinarily
compassionate of him
you know like we all like to hope that
we might react similarly to someone who
tormented us but
um most of us don't have that in us i
don't think
um so you're at ibm at this role and
then they say you know what you could
use some
some studies and so they ended up um
helping you go to depaul is that right
yeah so i started out as this just like
computer installer and then i worked my
way up to
an assistant researcher or system
project manager and then i became an
assistant researcher and then
i got hired onto ibm full time uh
started to lead a team in their smb and
their small medium business division
when the internet was just picking up
steam
uh and uh through the work that i had
done had started like over 12 quarters
um like had developed leads that were
like a quarter of a billion dollars so
at that point ibm was was very happy
with with my work i had
developed kind of this pioneering
research team there uh
in the sales department so they were
like yeah you know we should really you
need a degree and i was like yeah i
would agree with that so i went and i
got my degree as an adult
in international relations and
international business
and i spent almost i think seven years
or
almost eight years at ibm and i got my
degree from depaul during that time too
and i'm really grateful for that
wow what an arc that must have been so
that takes you through
a particular period and are you in touch
with your
um ex-wife and kids at that time um
yeah yeah yeah i never lost touch with
with my ex-wife and my kids you know it
was difficult with my ex-wife when we
went through the divorce but i always
wanted to be a good dad so i
always always had the kids every weekend
you know friday to monday as they were
growing up so i never
lost that connection with them and in
fact they're 28 and 26 years old they're
not little boys anymore
uh and uh yeah so uh they're doing great
and
they saved my life too i mean it hadn't
been for them to really challenge me
and for me to have to be honest with
them about who i was um
you know i don't know that i would have
made it this far so then
in 2000 you start telling your story
you're still working for ibm
um how did that transition look no
eventually you wound up writing these
books
starting these organizations working in
media yeah trying to get the word out
um was that a a big step i'm sure the
first time you started telling
people openly about your past that must
have been very very difficult
yeah i mean it really took i told very
very few people like from 2000 to 2003
it was you know i started to talk to
family and people that i knew my wife
who i'm you know been married to now for
for you know 15 years i've known for
almost 18 or 19 years um who also worked
at ibm at the time
it wasn't until 2003 when i went to
depaul that i really started to tell my
story and then
in 2004 when my brother was murdered
that's when i really started to do the
work that i'm doing now when i started
to focus on trying to help people
disengage
from hate groups because i realized at
that point that i hadn't
that i could have been a better big
brother to him uh
and that now i could probably try and do
that with other people that i didn't
know
that also needed kind of a you know a
guiding voice
so to speak well we're certainly glad
that you did and
you ended up writing a memoir that that
was
published in multiple countries
and have become an incredible figure
thank you
[Music]
okay i know how it is you've been
listening to a lot of stuff lately
including this podcast thank you
and you have wired your buds and you're
like
maybe i should spring for wireless
earbuds but you're afraid you're gonna
lose them
you're afraid they're too expensive now
if that describes you
you should definitely check out the new
wireless earbuds from raycon
i gotta say the newest model the
everyday e25 earbuds
their best ones yet six hours of play
time
more bass more compact design you can
listen to your own music and no one else
can hear it they can't even tell you
have earbuds in
they stay in your ears and are
comfortable
uh they look great but they're invisible
so them looking great is actually not
that big a deal
if this sounds like something you want
to check out and you can feel smart
about it because
it's really the same value for a lot
less money
all right honestly i like these things
because i like bumping the base
particularly on the subway
or just riding i ride the i ride a
scooter around new york city so i like
bumping the base i don't have to listen
to people or
frankly talk to people particularly in
covid so i think raycon's earbuds have
really really strong
audio quality which i love celebrities
think they're cool too uh so whether
it's snoop dogg
or even j.r smith who just won a title
and is not wearing a shirt
ever um right now these guys use them
they endorse the product the people who
like music or like what stylish
are big fans of this so for a limited
time get fifteen percent off your order
at buy raycon dot com slash yang that's
buy raycon dot com slash yang for a
special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds make
sure to check it out now
while this deal is running by raycon.com
yang
[Applause]
what is your approach to people who are
still radicalized and are struggling
because you have at this point
de-radicalized how many people would you
say
i mean it's it's impossible to put a
number on it but i've worked with over
600 people at various stages of their
disengagement you know from people
just for support because they got out on
their own to people who are actively you
know still in and working their way out
so
you know anywhere over 600 people i
think now
um i mean that's a lot of lives to have
touched
and thank you there's a lot of heart and
soul that goes into each one because you
you have to kind of live through your
own
uh dark moments of the soul in order to
be able to relate to folks who are
are struggling in that way that's really
important
i'm glad you brought that up yeah i'm
really glad that you brought that up and
that's really important you know i've
learned a lot about secondary trauma
uh in doing the work that i've been
doing and the idea of
when you are surrounded by other
people's trauma and you're constantly
dealing with
their trauma and sifting through and
helping them work through it that it
actually causes you
trauma you know on top of the the ptsd
that i still struggle with from from
those years having been involved but
also having caused
other people trauma and that you know if
anybody's listening and they're going
through that and they're in
kind of the field of dealing with other
people be really
cognizant of your own trauma that might
be building because of that
you know call it compassion fatigue call
it you know secondary trauma but be very
cognizant of that i've had to figure
that out
and i've had to do self-care for that uh
when i've noticed it so i'm really glad
that you brought that up because it's
very important
now we i've seen versions of it
myself in different ways certainly not
the same degree that you
you experience um you know one one story
i'll share
that is personal is that when my
my wife evelyn came out with her story
of being
sexually assaulted and then we were on
the trail and she would
uh talk to dozens of women who
thanked her but would also often be
carrying with them
like a similar experience and evelyn
would be helping them process through
their
um pain and anger and different things
and i would see evelyn after she would
talk to this group of people
and see that obviously she was very
happy and grateful but also it took a
lot out of
uh her just like it would take a lot out
of anyone um
and so for you i can see very clearly it
would be
it's not an easy thing like you know to
have talked to 600
people that have been through a version
of your journey and then you you have to
kind of um re uh
engage with like this this whole uh
arc that you went through um if you're
going to be able to help someone else
uh so it takes a lot it's one reason why
i think you are so important
and that there and that there aren't um
more people i mean i'm sure there are
some there are other people that have
gone through versions of your journey
um and so if i am someone who's
struggling
uh with trying to disengage from one of
these
uh movements or organizations uh like
what is your approach
to that person yeah and my new book
breaking hate
outlines the complete process that i use
and helping people disengage and also
uses stories that of people that i've
worked with
um but it really it kind of boils down
to
we have to understand the motivations of
why people are led to these movements oh
thank you very much
um and uh it's never it's typically
never the ideology that they're after
right the ideology is not attractive
it's illogical it's irrational to hate
somebody based on the color of their
skin i mean it's based on conspiracy
theories
and garbage so it's not the ideology
so we have to understand as people are
on this search for identity
community and purpose which we all are
at some point in our lives sometimes
multiple times in our lives
we hit what i call potholes in our
life's journey and potholes are things
like
physical trauma and abuse could be
mental illness it could be job loss it
could be grief it could be poverty it
can also be privileged
if privilege keeps us too separate from
humanity it could be millions of
different things it could be you know
getting
divorced and never really kind of
dealing with that and those potholes
lead us to the fringes they detour us
and on the fringes are all sorts of
narratives to try and comfort us to try
and
uh kind of take advantage of our
vulnerability uh things like you know
sex
traffickers are waiting there and gangs
are waiting there and you know drug
culture is waiting there but white
supremacists are waiting there too
to try and attract people with a
narrative that takes their pain
and projects it on to somebody else so
my goal when i work with people is
really to
listen uh very closely to those potholes
and then try and repair them as best as
i can because once the potholes are
repaired we can work on replacing
the toxic identity community and purpose
that they've found
that they're getting a reward from uh
with something that's more
positive and that's the process that i
use with everybody
you know i don't do it myself i find
people to help i find therapists and
um you know psychologists and job
trainers and life coaches to help that
person
but it really is all about kind of
repairing their foundation to bring them
back
on the path to find something more
positive
and what are the positive things and you
and i have talked about this
so first i think the notion of potholes
is
so important because i feel like at this
point potholes are almost more
commonplace than
smooth road yeah in american life uh
you know i mean especially now with this
pandemic where there are so many people
who
were working very hard
and trying to get ahead
or stay afloat and then now they've
gotten the legs kicked out from under
them and they're looking around saying
what the heck
you know i i i was
doing my best as i could as a
trucker bartender airline attendant
hair stylist personal trainer like you
know you name it like all these
servers like all these jobs that um have
gotten decimated as a result of the
pandemic
um so i i feel like potholes are now
like the new normal
in american life and i feel
societies can also have a you know
massive potholes american society like
people you know is on a really broken
search for its identity community and
purpose right now america
has its historical potholes that we've
never addressed that we've never fixed
things like slavery and inequity and and
you know how people have been held back
so until we fix that you know america is
also in is prime for radicalization
right now and i mentioned earlier that
it could happen at different stages i'm
also noticing with people who are newly
retired
so people in their 60s now are becoming
radicalized because like young people at
14
they're making new friends because
they're retired they don't have their
old career anymore sometimes they've
moved to a new city or a new state to
retire and they're
starting over with a new identity a new
community and purpose and
they have access to the internet which
is you know prime
uh platform and prime fodder for
radicalization so i really am very very
concerned
like you mentioned all these layers
pandemic unemployment and election
that's coming up
um you know job loss it's it is a
perfect storm
for for us to become radicalized right
now and it scares the [ __ ] out of me
it scares me too christian uh it's one
reason why i think
your experience is so important for us
to get out there and to
let people know uh what we can do better
um so we'll come back to what we can do
to build more positive pathways
for people um but i want to continue
with what you just said about the
internet um
so it's clear to most of us now that
social media is bad for our sense of
togetherness and wellness and we have
alternative uh facts and versions of
reality that we're experiencing the
social media companies are profiting
from that
it enhances division and it gives
a foothold to really hateful negative
ideologies so i wanted to go through a
very dark exercise and i apologize
if this is um difficult
but i want you to imagine when you were
at the the
height of your engagement in these
neo-nazi
organizations and gangs if you'd had the
internet um because
one thing that folks i think are
catching on from even this conversation
is that
you're a very entrepreneurial person uh
you know like it's very entrepreneurial
to
start a rock band to start a business
uh to help um
folks de-radicalize now your parents are
entrepreneurs
i want you to imagine if you'd had that
entrepreneurial
zealand energy and the internet existed
then the way it exists now
um like how would you have used it
that's a really dangerous question i
don't want to give anybody any ideas out
there
but yeah that's a really scary thought
you can
fall short of actually giving people a
quote-unquote like useful
um advice but i was just trying to paint
a picture as to
um the fact that right now the internet
feels like it would be an incredibly
uh powerful accelerant
uh to being able to spread hateful ideas
yeah no absolutely and i you know to one
in one degree i'm i'm so
glad that the internet didn't exist when
i was involved because i don't know that
we'd be talking now you know
if there was you know so much record
like exists you know for people today
because it really is hard to forgive
people um you know once
once it's kind of immortalized and you
know on the internet
um but yeah i mean i think i probably
would be using it a lot
like it is being used now as a platform
for propaganda
i was a propagandist i made music that
was
propaganda uh but you know we did it in
a very traditional way of pressing
records pressing cds
you know hustling you know out of
backpacks to try and sell that stuff and
eventually having a record store
had the internet existed then like it
does now you know i can i can see how
music
could have reached millions of people
instead of thousands of people
and music could have been used as a
really you know
powerful uh propaganda tool um but yeah
in many ways like they're doing now to
target vulnerable people
with a message uh that they can be
glorious that there is something better
that they can go
you know to this greatness kind of like
make america great again right
you're promising the hope hopeless hope
uh
and um uh yeah unfortunately i'm really
glad the internet didn't exist
back then to be honest but it's a
problem now well when you talk about the
ability to forgive yourself um
but then you're just saying hey we might
not be having this conversation because
the world would not have forgiven me
if all of my activities had been
immortalized in that way
that's like a very profound statement
that i think a lot of people can
understand and relate to like
if you have folks now who have done
things on the internet
and then now are trying to de-radicalize
i almost feel like they might look up
and be like well it's impossible for me
to de-radicalize because people are
going to attribute
these uh beliefs and activities to me
forever like even if i try and repudiate
them now
is that right yeah i mean i can't help
but think that had i
not started to talk about this publicly
you know almost 20 years ago and i'd be
in a position now where that's who i was
and nobody knew it
i would be terrified i think every day
of somebody finding out
publishing you know my name and my old
music like i'm
i i was forward thinking in the sense
that i wanted to come clean you know
almost 20 years ago but had i not i
might be terrified i know that there are
thousands of people out there who used
to be part of that
and maybe now are much much better
people have learned so much since they
were you know younger and involved in
that and now are probably living every
day like they're
scared of being found out and to them i
would say
just come clean you know i think if
you're genuine
and if you have you know sincerely done
enough to repair the damage that you've
caused
people will forgive you i've seen that
i've received
you know that forgiveness based on how
i've held myself accountable if you
haven't
you know done that work to repair the
damage you've done then start uh
because you know eventually why live
every day in fear at least live
you know with some kind of honor for
yourself that you're fixing what you
helped break
um but yeah i get it it's tough it's a
tough you know emotion
an emotional environment is really tough
to you know to find redemption and so
that's why i think i said what i'm
listening to this and thinking i that is
what i want for myself
like how do they reach out to you and
your organization like where do they go
uh if they're starting to explore what a
path out might look like
well they can always uh reach out to us
at free radicals.org
but there are also a lot of other people
you know other groups offering support
these days so they can just you know
kind of google
help with disengaging from extremism uh
but you know i'm also really easy to
find if you just kind of google x
skinhead i'm
typically the first person who pops up
in google search too
this is gonna be a random question but
can you take your cap off i just want to
see what your your hair is looking like
karma my friend this is karma you know i
shaved my head for so many years that
the minute i decided i was going to stop
shaving it you know
the higher power said you know what
screw you you're not going to get any
more hair
that but you could like uh you know i
mean i was just more
curious to joking about anything else
but you know in that case clearly you
know you've like
the head of hair is that many many of um
of men your age um our age because you
know you and i are about the same age
yeah is that right yeah if i'm 40 i'll
be 47
on i'll be 47 on election day november
3rd is my 47th birthday
well you may be getting a present my
friend i sure hope so
so one of the things you informed me of
when i was running is that look we have
to try and fill the potholes and then
provide positive pathways for people
yeah and they're different so you talked
about these junctures when someone can
become radicalized because they're
missing that sense of purpose community
structure
um i could not agree more like that the
goal to me
should be to crea create as many
environments and organizations and
situations where people feel that sense
of purpose community structure
it was very touching to me when you said
to me months ago where i said look
if instead of that skinhead coming to me
when i was 14 it had been
a coach or a community leader in a
positive way or a teacher like you know
i would have gone with that person too
you know like this those touch points
aren't there so what can we do to
provide more
of these positive pathways and what can
they look like
wow i mean i think that there are lots
of opportunities i mean i think to to
some degree
family and faith and and you know school
and all the things that we already you
know have in
in our society can provide really
positive pathways for that
but i also think you know we have to
maybe rethink how you know
we empower young people i think we're
failing young people and i think you
really
understood that really really well
during the campaign like and understood
how americans are behind
you know imagine a world where if for
their senior what if we brought back
um you know the idea of
uh the draft but it's not millet i'm not
talking about a military draft what if
senior year
our students were mandatorily supposed
to go out into the world to work for
civil society
they could volunteer for a non-profit
organization or an ngo
they could you know go understand what
it our government looks like they could
become a page in the senate or something
like that
but their senior year is working out in
the world with people
that are different than the ones they
grew up with and went to school with
imagine if if we paid imagine if we paid
them to do that andrew
we could give them college savings bonds
like american exchange program senior in
high school we send you someplace else
to vote absolutely and essentially it'd
be like kid swap
because if i've got a senior in high
school my kid's going to go someplace
else and like
sure i'll like have some kid from
another um
state or whatnot or a community and then
just from that exposure they would look
up and say wait a minute like you you
tell me
people are terrible in illinois it's
like i was there our facebook friends
were there
my vision was that this exchange program
you go and there are like clusters
of 25 of you from different communities
and then
it's not just you interacting with the
folks in that community you're going to
interact with 24
other seniors who are from all over the
country
absolutely and pay them to do it give
them you know have cash
because they are working in the real
world and give them savings bonds to use
towards college so then
when they're done with that year they
have a head start on college that
kind of helps you know two things get
the inability to pay for school that is
such a problem in our country
but also you know this this problem of
polarization and not having the
experience in the real world
and i think that that may be you know
what we need to start preparing young
people for is
is let them lead and and let's put them
in positions
where we can empower them instead of
prescribe what we think
you know the solution is maybe that's
where we're failing we're failing young
people on multiple levels
christian um and we we need to
reinvest in our people and like you said
empower and trust them uh to
help carve out what their
opportunities and livelihoods and
businesses and organizations
can should look like i'm a huge believer
in entrepreneurship for this reason
and i think something like the american
exchange program would be immensely
helpful
i think universal basic income would be
immensely helpful because
if you're a young person you look up and
you are struggling with a path forward
right now there's like a sense that no
one values you no one believes in you
no one's willing to invest in you and so
we said to young people it's like hey
guess
what here's a thousand bucks like uh you
know the first month they'd be like this
is too good to be true
they like you know maybe do something
like um
uh like somewhat uh you know fun-loving
with it or whatnot but then
you know people can sense when you're
investing in them people can sense when
you're bullshitting them too
if you actually said look we love you we
value you we care about you and here's
an investment in you and your future it
could be in the form of a bond for
school it could be
just economic resources that's a game
changer because most people right now
don't feel like we
uh care about them that we see them
yeah no i hear you and and that feeling
of invisibility is really tough because
some
some people will go out of their way to
amplify really bad
things to to be seen and i think we're
in this moment right now where it's just
every it's like a feedback loop where
everybody's screaming louder and having
to scream louder at each other
until you know it's just one
high-pitched noise that that
none of us can bear uh and i'm really
i'm really worried about our future
because how you know we need to we need
steps to come back from this
and uh you know i work with people
one-on-one but i worry about our society
in general and how you know how we come
back from this
and i really hope that there is a spot
in the administration for you because i
really
think so many of your ideas were game
changers and i think a lot of people
really saw that and and bought on to
that
thank you christian i think you're a
game changer yourself
uh and i think we need to try and create
an army or a multitude of you
um is that possible like are there other
people who've been
in and then out of these hate groups
that could
uh become uh d converters or d
radicalizers uh in the same way that
you are like is it conceivable that we
could build
a whole force of christian peacholini
perhaps less
you know less cool
better looking i hope i don't know or
you know like less
like um you know i i mean there'd
obviously be
variations because you know people are
all um distinct and unique
uh but are there more people like you
who'd want to do the same kind of work
absolutely there are already and they're
already doing great work we call our you
know we call ourselves formers or
somebody else made that name up and we
kind of just adopted it but there are
farmers out there who spent time in
these movements who've done the work to
repair the damage they've done and are
now doing this work but i think even
more than that
we already have the tools in our society
to fix this we have
you know psychologists and therapists
and job trainers and life coaches and
counselors and
and all you know all this stuff that we
can utilize they just don't know that
they can do this work because it really
is about the work of human resilience so
if we can just train them if we can just
make them aware that
hey they never have to have an
ideological debate they never have to
you know talk about ideology with people
it's really just about
fixing their potholes then i think
that's how we scale this immediately is
just letting the people that exist out
there
who know how to do the work of building
people back
just let them know that they can do and
i've actually been working on curriculum
to try and
and you know instruct some of these
people uh so you don't need a bunch of
me
you we just need to to re-leverage the
tools that exist already
i think we need them both personally
well when when someone hears that too
they think you know
sure we have psychologists and uh life
coaches and job trainers and social
workers and everything else
but it seems like the average person
struggling with
hatred or membership in one of these
organizations does not have
access or resources for
those services um and i'm not going to
ask you a personal question that's
that i'm i'm genuinely curious about so
you're a former
like uh let's say there were a thousand
people like you
um where would the funding come from
right now in my mind
this should clearly be something that
the public would be funding to the
nth degree where anyone who's like hey
i'm a former hate group member would
like to de-radicalize others you're
being like don
whatever you need we should be supplying
it to you
and just freaking knocking down your
door to like help equip you
i wish it were that easy man but i know
that's not the way the world works
like and and you know i'm i understand
activism so uh first
where do your resources come from
because you obviously put a lot of time
and energy and everything else into it
and two
like where should we be getting the
resources for this
army of formers yeah uh
you know ever since i've been doing this
i have self-funded this work so i do a
lot of speaking engagements last year in
2019 i was on the road 50
of the time you know like in six
countries
20 different states and i 100 of the
funds that i use
that i charge for my speaking gigs go to
pay for the services and go to fund the
organization
other than that we take donations at
freeradicals.org
i've stopped asking the government for
money because
the one time i did that uh you know and
we actually won a 400
000 grant with my old organization under
president obama the minute the
administration changed
and president trump was in uh power they
rescinded that grant without ever having
paid it
um and so i i promised myself i was
going to stop asking the government
until
the administration changed uh so in the
meantime uh you know it's been a little
bit of a struggle to be honest because
of covet you know i'm not speaking on
the road as much so
um i'm doing everything virtually and
it's been a struggle
um but other countries do do it right
there you know there's a group in sweden
uh that's been doing this for you know
over a decade a group in germany
that's made up of formers and
professional practitioners
with government support and they've been
able to help hundreds and hundreds of
people disengage so it can be done
but with the current administration with
the current infrastructure
the only thing that they're doing is is
increasing radicalization to be honest
uh in the last four years it has just it
has been out of control and overwhelming
the amount of people that have been you
know radicalized by careless rhetoric
uh by you know kind of both scientism
type talk and then
you know just the influx of propaganda
that we've seen in the last four years
online
it's been kind of a nightmare well i'm
personally going to make a donation to
freeradicals.org
after uh this conversation i'd encourage
others to do the same
what is the size of the opportunity set
like if someone were to come i think 400
000 from the obama administration like
well that's good and then the fact they
never had an opportunity to pay it
because of the change over that's
terrible
uh to to me this should be
a multi-million dollar uh effort
easily i mean heck if i were in the
white house and we were having this
conversation i'd be like write this man
a blank check
because like any money we not even you
individually i mean obviously the org um
and and it would be like hey i want to
come back and see like a thousand
christians like doing this work
this is like to me uh because i want to
say something that you know
like it's um we should not settle for
denunciation i mean the fact that the
president could not denounce white
supremacy is
awful and obviously emboldened folks
with hateful ideologies
but it is not enough to for us to come
and say like look this this
is wrong like we have to be real
about the fact that uh this is happening
and
it's preying upon uh people who are
struggling in different ways and we have
to invest
in um trying to make it better you know
that this isn't like hey if i
send out the right worded statement like
it's gonna be
better like you know that's not the way
this works at all you know it's like if
you want to uh to defeat extremist
ideologies you have to
invest in real solutions and to me you
are
the i appreciate that the
paradigm bearer of what those solutions
can and should look like
i appreciate it and i've got a you know
four free radicals project i've got a 1
million 3 million 5 million
you know multi-year plan to scale to
grow
it includes case managers around the
country it includes hiring formers as
part of
um the bridge building process because
they do trust formers you know
as kind of the first person that they
reach out to but we also have a whole
network of psychologists
job trainers that we're building there
are research studies that we're involved
in that we're working on
and and uh right now it you know again
free radicals has no employees including
me i've never been paid and we have all
volunteers across
the world who are helping do this work
it would really be
you know to help scale this and solidify
it
has always been a dream of mine except
sometimes and most days i feel like
you know the little dutch boy with his
finger in the dike and if i pull my
finger out of the dike it all kind of
kind of comes crumbling down
so i've enlisted people recently to kind
of help build the organization around me
but we could
you know use your support and i'm sure
the plan you know the 1 million 3
million 5 million plan to grow with
anybody who's interested to
well go to freeradicals.org check out
christian's work
support it if you want to read the book
it's outstanding
breaking hate did i move my copy
look at that um breaking hate uh he also
wrote a book
um before this um call white american
youth
white american youth oh yeah that's
um yeah so white american youth it was
the first book breaking hate is the more
recent book uh i highly recommend them
both freeradicals.org
uh christian you are
a leader uh who's doing incredibly
important work
uh we need to support you and we need to
make it so that you are
not as singular as you are because there
are many people who have struggled with
what you've been through
um and they want to do better and they
want to repair the harms that they've
done
that they've and inflicted upon others
we need to give them that opportunity we
need to give our country an opportunity
to genuinely
combat some of these ideologies because
your fears
we all share like if anyone looks up and
says hey do i think things are getting
worse and nastier or better like most of
us think we're getting worse and nastier
for a variety of reasons and
we shouldn't just worry about it we
should do something about it and you are
doing something about it every single
day
so in addition to free radicals.org the
book um
do you have uh anything else that people
would love to hear about
oh thanks for asking andrew yeah
actually i've got a new podcast with
wbez in chicago it's an npr affiliate in
chicago it's called motive
season three and it explains the how the
white supremacist youth movement started
in the mid 80s
and kind of morphed into what we're
seeing in charlottesville and in places
today and i think it does a really good
job of explaining that so
thanks for asking no problem
christianpicholini freeradicals.org
check
him out and his work let's support him
and let's actually invest in some of the
solutions that he's been working on for
years thank you christian
thank you andrew appreciate you too my
friend peace
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you